Do you want the secret to the most delicious scalloped potatoes?
You have to make sure that you're slicing the potatoes evenly
and consistently, and that's really hard to do by hand,
so I prefer a little gadget.
I got this one from the TikTok shop.
It suctions to your work surface.
It has, like,
three different blades, but it's gonna make sure that the potatoes
are the exact same thickness,
every single one of them. It also keeps your hands safe,
like you never get close to the blade at all,
and everything is perfectly even and uniform.
You take all those potatoes,
takes minutes to slice them,
boil them in a pot with heavy cream and chicken broth
and all these spices listed on the screen.
Bake it with some cheese all in between and on top,
and top with whatever fresh herbs you like. Enjoy.